[Applaudissements]
à 91
incroyable non non
incroyable tous ces gens que je
regardais à la télé que j'aimais sont là
maintenant
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu voudrais dire à
Laurent d'abord je voudrais Isabelle que
je te reconnais parce que c'est gentil
[Rires]
de gens
le fromage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu as bien dit que c'était Mireille qui
avait composé la musique et ces gens-là
je crois qu'elle fait le sexe
parce que nous nous voyons pas assez
souvent mais nous sommes
amoureux canus ce qui est un peu
d'histoire savent ce que c'est
des ouvriers qui s'occupaient de lui
il est pauvre canule il avait rien à
manger et les riches les milliardaires
comme il y en a là dernièrement
et là et bien les riches mangeaient de
la cervelle d'agneau avec de l'échalote
de l'huile etc et les pauvres ils
mangent rien alors qu'ils ont
deux crèmes fraîche et les mêmes et les
mêmes échalotes
la cervelle de Camus et c'est pour ça
que vous avez reconnu Isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne le connais pas encore alors
attention au dernier test on commence
j'ai combien de doigts
énormes stars Marie pervenge on vous
appelle encore marine dans la rue oui
c'est vrai tout le temps
qui nous écoute moi je
regarde
et je me dis je devrais redescendre dans
la rue je mettrai un peu de rangement
là-dedans
vous voulez refaire la série où est
vraiment contractuel j'aimerais être
avec toi mais imaginez
pas contractuel la suite
oh mais j'arrive avec mon costume bleu
bébé c'est pas clair faut vraiment qu'on
se parle parce que attends reposons-nous
est-ce que vous voulez refaire la suite
et rejouer Le roi est vraiment
contractuel dans la vie imaginez
ez pas pris de mythe d'accord quand
je descends le bordel en ce moment et
puis on me remarquerait et je me ferai
obéir ah ben ça j'en doute pas donc vous
voulez la suite c'est un premier scoop
parce qu'effectivement
parce que c'est vrai que vous dites
aussi que c'est d'autant plus étonnant
que vous il y a eu que 22 épisodes pour
Marie pervenche et les derrière toutes
les Julie Lescaut et les machins il y en
a eu des centaines elle prenait 100000 €
par épisode vous que 22 pourquoi parce
que c'était du temps de la télévision
publique et alors n'est-ce pas
c'est tout on gagne moins d'argent oui
ça a été Bouygues vous étiez pied
combien par épisode oh bah le minimum
épisode combien
par jour
et c'était combien de jours de tournage
pas beaucoup c'est à dire
pour un épisode tu pars c'était 20 jours
par épisode donc j'en ai tourné 22 par
20 voilà donc ça fait donc ça fait 600 x
20 12000 euros pour un épisode ah bah
c'est sûr que Mimi Mathy prenez 150000
pour faire ça ben écoutez c'est en plus
j'y vais avec mon mari et socialiste
donc
du coup les impôts alors vous avez dit
j'aurais dû être très riche et pense que
j'étais marié avec sa race non
c'est Véronique Coluche qui a été envoyé
de chasse même pas du tout excusez-moi
je suis désolé mais là pour les gens qui
nous regardent il y a je t'ai reconnu
tes Isabelle lui il croit qu'on est en
88 et il y a sa race et que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre là on l'appelle
Chantal les gars
[Musique]
on est à TPMP là c'est Daniel Evenou là
c'est Isabelle qui est sur RTL et là
c'est Laurent Fontaine qui aujourd'hui
est un petit peu voilà oui j'ai un tout
petit but compris
au futur roi du Maroc
[Rires]
Mohamed VI par rapport avec moi des
durétiques
par jour pour ta molle ça règle ma
prostate ça rapporte
à 6h du mat une blague là
cette émission Daniel la prostate c'est
exactement comme vous savez ce que c'est
un réservoir d'essence la prostate de
Razer redescence devait un bouchon qui
se balade et quand il y a plus d'essence
il touche les côtés et la lumière
s'allume en vieillissant la prostate il
y a un truc comme ça mais qui se dérègle
et donc il tousse les côtés il vous
indique que vous avez une faire pipi
alors qu'il vous dit rien c'est moi
d'abord
j'ai perdu
michel Cymes maintenant alors est-ce que
vous auriez aimé alors on va essayer de
continuer là vous faites beaucoup de
théâtre en revanche beaucoup beaucoup de
théâtre voilà et alors j'ai lu Bernard
Minet ah ouais vous a massacré dans une
interview pas sympa
au club de roter elle a fait une
apparition clin d'oeil dans la série
sitcom du club Salut les Musclés ça a
été une horreur elle était odieuse elle
nous a pris de haut cette femme voulait
humilier les gens
je suis capable de faire du mal mais
vous n'êtes pas aller au Club Dorothée
dans Salut les Musclés bah s'ils le
disent ça doit être vrai mais vous ce
n'est pas salut les musclés
[Musique]
il est là
mais je connais pas de Bernard Minet
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas posé une question c'est lunaire
et là pendant la pub je vous jure que
c'est vrai Daniel va voir Isabelle et
lui dit il faut que tu fasses une
coloscopie très importante c'est très
important
vous dormez mais j'adore être endormi
parce que
non presque bien quand on vous fait une
coloscopie c'est que ça vous vide la
tête
[Rires]
parce que j'ai saoulé complètement parce
que tous les gens tous les gens qu'on a
déjà fait une à partir de 50 ans comme
nous je te promets que les produits
qu'on devait faire de prendre deux jours
avant tu es pas England
toutes les semaines j'appelle mon
médecin souvent je ferai mais mon chou
le trou de la Sécu
toute façon moi j'aimerais me faire
opérer tout le temps parce que j'adore
être endormi parce que je suis un
somniaque alors j'ai tout dit ça reste
oui mais vous avez vu
et surtout de voir mais à propos de vous
aimez tout mais c'est parce que vous
aimez être endormi et l'hôpital que vous
avez fait vous en parler autant de
chirurgie tout ça ou vous êtes contente
de la chirurgie ou comme certains comme
Emmanuel Béart vous la regrettez
j'ai fait une bête j'allais très très
bien surtout
et un jour je vais mais vous la
connaissez l'histoire mais est-ce que
vous regrettez
tout le monde se disait chirurgien
esthétique mais mon chou on va passer
d'un dentiste aussi pour se faire opérer
du foie qu'est-ce que je vous dise
enfin quand même quelle horreur
[Rires]
mais depuis non non
tout va bien
vous montrer un truc très mignon elle a
mis un petit papier avec les prénoms de
chroniqueurs comme ça on sait jamais
comme ça on sait jamais c'est trop
mignon non mais moi je te trouve très
belle donc je ne trouve pas moi quelque
chose à la règle comme ça si vous voulez
pas répondre vous répondez pas
non mais parce que vous avez une
poitrine magnifique et on demandait avec
Jean-Mi mais avec un compliment
on te disait avec Jean-Mi c'est très
réussi vous avez une très jolie poitrine
non
c'est une longue histoire
j'ai eu un bon
je vous raconte ma douce que ça ça
durait deux émissions ah non un jour on
a cru que j'avais une saloperie une
couleur où ça donc
ils m'ont retirait un petit mot pour
savoir si Cancé
et avec le temps ils m'ont fait un trou
non comme d'hab
pas du tout et mon mari mon grand amour
georges était furieux contre celui qui
m'a opéré c'est-à-dire un opérateur
qu'on appelle ça aussi c'était pas le
bon médecin
mais le temps passe et pour
l'anniversaire de mon mari George filiou
nous cherchons un cadeau tous et moi
j'ai eu l'idée ça sert le sein gauche
quand vous allez chez Midas si tu as une
roue qui a 30 % tu changes
mes amis et mon ami belarmier
il y a pas de Bernard alors je suis
embêté
une carrosserie neuve plus vieille
bagnole et moi j'ai offert un genre une
nouvelle carrosserie
il est mort
et lorsque mon mari est mort et que je
voyais plus mes chaussures c'est pour
ils étaient là-bas
alors je voulais vous demander pendant
que vous avez été très honnête ça c'est
un petit moment touchant vous êtes moi
je vous ai filmé chez vous
dans le dans un appartement à Paris
pendant 3 jours je trouve que vous êtes
en plateau tout le temps très très drôle
vous avez la politesse d'être gay on va
dire chez vous je vous ai trouvé plus
mélancolique quand on se parlait quand
le journaliste vous parlait et je
voudrais plus maintenant colique un peu
plus triste et d'ailleurs pendant le
confinement vous avez dit j'avais le
sentiment de ne pas exister et je me
suis mis à beaucoup boire d'abord j'ai
trouvé ça très honnête non mais pourquoi
parce que je vous promets je vois
beaucoup de pharmaciens des
psychothérapeutes et tout ça moi je peux
vous dire c'est ma vie
ils m'ont tous dit que de l'après covid
effectivement les ordonnances qui voient
c'est fascinant donc je trouve ça très
honnête de parler de ces choses là c'est
vous qui n'avez parlé c'est pas moi j'ai
dit dans une émission de Laurent Ruquier
mais avec mon humour de merde oh j'ai dû
mais j'ai vu quoi pendant le confinement
j'ai bu mais comme une blague ça a été
pris au premier
degrés je me suis mise à boire
maintenant je ne bois pas principe dire
plus du tout j'ai des poissons
j'ai décidé de fumer mais j'y arrive pas
problème
du sport
du karcher
comment on appelle genre le fruit merci
je bois du jardin
excusez-moi j'ai une question apporte
aussi vous qui avez dit pendant le
confinement il n'y avait pas d'heure et
vous étiez sérieuse le bruit du bouchon
me mettait dans un étage je n'ai pas
honte de le dire je me suis mise à aimer
à boire parce que j'étais seul toute
seule et j'ai beaucoup bu du vin ça
c'est pas drôle c'est vrai mais c'était
très touchant
pourquoi de temps en temps on casse pas
un petit peu le bouclier on se dit pas
les choses j'ai appris non mais je ne
dis plus rien mais non mais au contraire
c'est pas là je ne suis même pas là mais
si mais au contraire et là ils veulent
tous mais que ce soit Martin chérie qui
veulent toujours écouter les
chroniqueurs en face j'ai cru que les
auditeurs allaient trouver il y a des
personnes qui sont dit la pauvre mais
non mais
c'est un tout petit peu parce que vous
êtes tout le temps drôle et je vous
adore vous savez parfois je vais citer
du Voltaire mais on n'est jamais
ridicule quand on est sincère moi je moi
par exemple je ne mens jamais là je dis
que je vois un psy tous les tous les
mercredis tous les machins je crois que
j'ai fait une dépression je l'ai dit
quand j'allais bien je l'ai dit quand je
dis des bêtises je le dis
voilà je raconte pas toute ma vie mais
je m'en parle j'essaie de casser un peu
le bouclier je pense que c'est important
pour les gens et qui nous écoutent et
qu'on se parle vraiment si je conseille
voir un psychologie
parce que je venais de subir des
écrevettes bon j'avais quelques soucis
lorsque j'ai rencontré il m'a dit tu vas
aller voir le professeur moralité pas
très bon lui
mais c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il est
moins bon
je vais voir mon rallye d'animaux et au
bout de trois fois il me dit Daniel mais
vous vous allez très très bien voilà qui
va pas bien mais vous vous allez bien
alors pour faire plaisir tous les
mercredis je vous inviterai à déjeuner
oh bah dis donc mais je suis pas devenu
sa maîtresse mais nous avons bien
déjeuné alors je suis un peu peur juste
pas besoin vous savez que dernièrement
et c'est voilà il y a l'une des femmes
de Jacques Martin maillon Game qui est
qui est décédé et et voilà c'est vrai
que dans une vous étiez vraiment pas
copine je trouve que vous avez
l'élégance de ne rien dire derrière
d'ailleurs
mais voilà c'est pour pour dire voilà
j'ai pas de question quand je pose une
question
vraiment
c'est triste de mourir aussi mais elle a
elle avait quitté Jacques quelque chose
de pas très intéressant
vous avez été en fait pardon de le dire
je vais alors je ne choque alors ah
c'est 8 je ne choque personne parce que
on dit ça comme ça
non je vais pas le dire mais vous êtes
une non je peux pas le dire vous êtes
une star qui aime bien coucher avec des
stars il y a un mot plus vulgaire vous
êtes sortis
que je parte vous êtes sortis avec ça il
va à la liste vous voulez que je mange
Jacques Brel et alors je vais pas dire
ça quand à Jacques Martin lorsque je
l'ai rencontré il était moins connu que
moi il était son boulot et c'est vrai il
y avait pas de reproches mais Jacques
Brel c'était comment et d'un artiste
tellement
pourquoi
j'avais l'époque j'avais 25 ans et donc
j'avais envie de voyager encore coquine
je comprends très bien pour toi c'est
pas pour toi qu'il écrit ne me quitte
pas
en revanche quelqu'un m'a écrit une
chanson
Alain Barrière mais c'est quoi la
tu dis des mots encore des mots toujours
les mêmes tu dis parfois tu dis souvent
je sens que régie sont là je vois pas du
tout mon Spotify c'est pas sorti c'est
sorti
est-ce que vous êtes la chanter est-ce
que vous avez un regret par exemple de
pas avoir des chances alors le mot
regret je n'aime pas l'entendre ni le
lire ni l'écrire aujourd'hui
oui
non mais aujourd'hui sans rire est-ce
que vous êtes heureuse moi je vous ai
trouvé très mal en colique quand je vous
ai tourné chez vous je vous ai trouvé à
l'époque un petit peu seul je vous ai
trouvé le support pas la solitude
beaucoup beaucoup des autres je vous ai
filmé à l'époque vous étiez seul le soir
chez vous et c'était j'avais une autre
personne qui était là j'avais on a
enlevé le masque qui est tellement
rigolo ce masque de clown que vous
faites très bien mais c'est une je me
suis levé comme ça ça sert à rien de se
plaindre ça sert à rien de se plaindre
mais ma question c'était est-ce que vous
êtes heureuse
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quoi vous avez le droit de
dire vous savez il y a oui il y a non et
puis est-ce que répondait justement
Barbara qui avait dit je ne suis pas
malheureuse et c'est déjà beaucoup
j'aimerais revivre une grande histoire
mais elle va arriver
[Musique]
qui a du caca
là on va continuer un petit peu est-ce
que est-ce que l'amour n'est pas là
puisque maintenant on va parler de vivre
avec une star est-ce que vous pourriez
revivre avec une star aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pourriez vivre avec
quelqu'un de connu certes des gens
rigocentriques égoïste qui prend génial
des gens connus
[Rires]
alors il y a parce qu'il a Philippe qui
va sa tête filou
mais je veux
bien ils ont pas 14 ans ici
tu choisis